ce midi le ciel est tombé sur la tête
des belfortains l'orage était attendu
mais le chiffre annoncé de 1000 emplois
supprimés sème la tristesse et la colère
dans la rue et chez les commerçants
aujourd'hui on peut se dire que 1044
emplois qui disparaissent d'un côté
c'est en gros trois mille emplois qui
vont disparaître sur ce territoire
c'est un désastre et je dirais que si on
voulait détruire un territoire
on s'y prendrait pas autrement
applications concrètes dans ce
restaurant qui jouxte les bâtiments de
general electric
un commerce repris en mars dans cette
salle de chefs sert chaque midi une
trentaine de repas et une soixantaine de
sandwichs aux salariés de general
electric prend sa chance sur le site du
technopole et environ 7000 personnes
donc si on enlève donc tous confondus
donc sur la nef déjà 1000 personnes
effectivement ces nouvelles nous faire
une perte c'est significatif sur la
songhua c'est une claque grosse claque
pour tout le monde en centre ville
l'annoncé était redouté est la réaction
est identique quels que soient les
générations interrogé le dépit que
malgré ce port est malheureux n'a déjà
pas grand chose les retraités mais la
prison des enfants postulent à prévoir
l'avenir c'est pas toujours évident nous
on empile moi j'ai déjà un pied dans la
tombe mais il faut qu'ils vivent ça va
être pire on galère déjà à trouver du
travail
moi personnellement je finis mes études
et on a tous pour objectif nous en étant
jeune de partir d'ici il n'ya plus assez
travail si on ça fonctionne pas en fait
les belfortains les plus optimistes
espèrent une réaction du gouvernement
pour limiter la casse mais avec cette
annonce de suppressions massives d
emplois seulement deux jours après les
résultats des élections européennes
ils n'ont plus vraiment la foi